well president Trump will travel to
Pittsburgh today to visit survivors of
the synagogue shooting funerals for
victims begin this morning dr. Jerry
Rabinowitz along with brother Cecil and
David Rosenthal will be buried today
eight men and three women were killed
Saturday in the deadliest attack on Jews
in US history
Nicky beti spoke to Holocaust survivor
Judah salmon he has been at a congregant
at the Tree of Life synagogue for more
than half a century on Saturday he said
he arrived a few minutes late which
actually may have saved his life as the
shootings happening and in the aftermath
are you thinking back to the Holocaust
how do you reconcile that you've
survived you've survived two of the
worst attacks on the Jewish community
ever
it never stops at least for me and my
family never stops it just keeps going
but we are survivors
you know I'm 80 years old I told my
daughter that I'm ready whenever you
know I'm not afraid of death what is
your message to the country love is much
easier to make what a great message well
Sam it says he knew all 11 victims and
does not look forward to seeing empty
seats when he returns to the synagogue
you're so right beyond and he's right to
love is much easier than hate I just
wonder how long it's going to take for
all of us to get it we need it now real
soon enough more than ever it's very
very scary to me